all right thank you all for the applause
thank you thank you
yes all right so this is a very very
special edition of beginner breakdown
tonight we are commemorating our six
year anniversary here at the Chess Club
in scholastic center of st. Louis and
tonight we have a guest mr. Tim Meacham
he was my opponent for for this game and
it's a stellar game wasn't it yeah it
sure was yeah it was great all right and
and you oh yeah yeah yeah I get to that
yeah
so Tim B Nigel short in a Simon using
the Sicilian kind yeah yeah it was great
it was great and he was so nice he sat
down I had the white piece here the
black pieces he told me that right
before we played yeah so that was a
great idea always tell your opponent
what you're going to play your pet
opening that you can be grandmasters
with it right before you sit down and
play all right so here we go here's the
game I start out a four and Tim plays
the Sicilian c5 and now I play c3 yeah
you sure word wish and I play Knight f3
so you could go into the kana huh but I
didn't cuz you told me how good you were
okay so I played c3 and so he plays
Knight to f6 attacking my e pawn ok so
there's no good way for me to protect my
pawn and I don't want to lose it so I
attack his Knight so Tim places his
knight on d5 so I attack it ok so he
doesn't want to protect it with d6 or
anything or east 6 that would you know
lead the double pawns so he attacks me
okay and now I want to play like Paul
Morphy
I never want to retreat all right I just
take it right - um okay so what move can
I play to protect my bishop here because
I don't want to move my bishop even
though it's probably advisable for me to
retreat my bishop I'm in no mood to
retreat so I decided to play b3 and
protect it not a good idea cuz now Tim
can just give me double pawns okay so it
takes and now I have double points so he
plays this Knight out to attack mighty
pawn here all right so what move should
I make in this position so we here
Knight of three f4 protects the pawn
okay because we want all the support
because if we only have Knight of three
that Knights got a lot of responsibility
to protect that pawn pawns are good for
protecting other points okay and then he
plays d6 attacks my pawn so I play d4 to
protect my pawn okay and so so he
captures my pawn here but he overlooks a
move I can make here that will give me a
slight advantage yeah so he's expecting
me to capture right back okay
but pawns can also move forward and now
when I attacked the knight is removing
the defender of this pawn so he plays
Knight to a5 and now I capture and yeah
he thought about capturing this pawn but
then he thought wow that's no good
why is Knight takes pawn no good so you
have a knight in your opponent's
territory unprotected
so what move can we make here
Queen to a4 check attacking the knight
and the King simultaneously Bishop
blacks Queen and there we're up a piece
everybody wants to get into this lecture
standing room only here alright so so
okay so he does not want to play takes
the pawn so he plays ecigs
so now I could play the move
d6 here okay now even though it looks
pretty good because it's a protected
pass pawn deep in his territory it's
very easy to remove this defender with
ideas like the dreaded f6 or something
like that too and then once this pawn
goes this D pawn will follow all right
all right so so e six so what do we do
it we don't want to play d6 we
definitely don't want to take this pawn
or I'll still trade the Queen's and it
will all fall apart for me so do we have
any any ideas just Knight f3 yeah it's
about time we get one of our pieces off
the back row huh yeah yeah all right get
a piece off the back row good
that's illegal yeah it's legal it's good
so he plays a move that shocks me here
yeah it was it was a stunner yep b5 okay
so so he's attacking my pawn
pretty pretty tight so it's actually a
pretty good move because I'm forced to
just take it there's no other line that
was the best move so he takes and now
he's got these two nice pawns okay
I wouldn't be I wouldn't be alright so
so now I get a piece off the back world
Bishop to g5 alright I'm hoping he plays
f6 also hoping he plays Bishop to e7
yeah well anyway it's going to be good
because if he plays Bishop e7 I take
Queen takes yeah yeah the best move in
this position is actually King takes the
best shot so so that's no good for him
so he can't play Bishop e7 f6 is also
horrible so what move does he have to
make here what's his only move that
doesn't lose material retakes Bishop is
not advisable because the knight
protects it but if you were thinking
that at home yeah it's always good to
look for your captures but but not for
too long okay so Queen to b6 doesn't
work because it still hangs the the D
pawn so what's the only move it has in
this position that doesn't lose material
anybody it's not a tough one all right
my queens are under attack my queen is
also protecting the D pawn I want both
of those things to happen Queen to d7
thank you yeah Queen Queen to d7 all
right all right so if you thought that
move was hard just wait for the move
that's coming up so white castles here
all right so now he's got the castle
going and so now black plays a very
interesting move here he just moved his
Queen once and so he moves the Queen
again to e6 alright so so this is when I
play the best move of my life okay so
even though it doesn't look like there's
any good moves here but I'll talk you
through it and hopefully you can play
like me one day
right so so my bishop is on g5 right but
who do I really want on g5 the night
right so I have to clear out a path to
the bishop
okay so Justin might be on to something
so if we play Bishop just back or
something he could maybe play Bishop to
e7 here okay so we want something
foreseen in this position yes
all right so Justin Justin's on fire
tonight so the move actually is Bishop
to d8 okay so so when the bishop goes to
d8 it attacks the night and if the King
takes the bishop right I can play my
knight here attacking the Queen and if
the Queen moves I take with check
forking the king and the rook it's a
pretty good move there so what did you
think about that move uh Tim whoa whoa
it's a family show you want me to stick
that Bishop where whoa yeah countdown
all right calm down here calm down
all right so so when Bishop to d8 I
attack the knight so so he sees this so
he doesn't take the bishop he decides to
play with his own threat
he plays Knight to c4 threatening his
own fork
Knight and Brooke okay it makes sense
all right so so now what do you think I
play so I have my own plan here
and so Knight to g5 you just stick with
the plan alright so so now he he sticks
with he rules his queen out of danger
here and attacks my Bishop e6 no good
yeah it's gotta be cuz he would just
take it right so so what like you come
home why give him up on just take it
just take it okay and so now he got his
uh his for kin so Queen to f3 Queen and
rook going down on the same file pretty
strong but he's got to take my my rook
so he took my rook so I better take his
rook okay alright so now he plays Queen
to f5 offering the Queen trade but so I
mean do I want to trade should I want to
trade chance so we got Queen to d5 as a
suggestion all right
the move I should play as Queen takes f1
then he takes I take he takes I check he
moves I move and that leaves me up up on
all right so that's what I should play
but I decided to be funny again he he
couldn't take my bishop once today
because it led to a losing variation so
I decided to taunt him again okay oh I
couldn't get the best night I just
couldn't resist taunting him but so he
can't take my bishop here okay if he
takes my bishop I have a really good
move here anybody have any ideas not you
yet
what uh what what's a good move here
check check
always check yep King there and then oh
I got your bishop
and then I'm gonna get your night okay
and now I'm up a piece and I'm doing
great okay so we can't take my bishop
even though it looks like free bishop so
he takes pawn takes and now I'm like
this is great
your knight is stuck it's stuck on the
edge of the bird nowhere to go I'm gonna
get that night and I'm gonna be a
superstar but so we can't move the
knight but that doesn't mean he has to
lose it
Bishop h3 Bishop h3 protects the night
and now I'm not not that happy anymore
because my Knights kind of trapped back
here hand up and his Knights trap but
you know it's got to be really tough for
me to take it all right so all right
play my night out the a3 now my rook is
threatening to take the knight all right
that would leave me with three pieces in
with two so I might try that so he plays
the discovery c4 all right so now Bishop
attacking my knight all right I better
move my knight huh
all right so I move my knight all right
so yeah yeah you see a Czech play a
Czech rear right right right mr. nerim
yep so check and so now so now I decide
I'm gonna block it with my knight okay
so my knight is now stuck okay it's a
pin piece that can't move stuck okay so
my knight really isn't doing very hot
here okay he's stuck all right all right
so now he's got an idea
all right King f8 oh so yeah so now
everybody knows what black's next move
is gonna be right yeah King g8 yeah
he's just gonna
I keep marching and my nights gonna be
so I better I better figure something
out really quick or else it's gonna be
uh yeah it's gonna be trouble so what
should I play man wait what should I
play rook takes Knight okay so so let's
say I do play rook takes Knight here so
Bishop takes King takes and now he's
still guys King g8 and my knight is uh
my Knights of dead man so oh man yeah
it's a good thing I'm showing you guys
this side so look he's gonna play King
to g8 if I don't if I don't if I don't
get a safe spot for this night to go
it's all it's Kearns well hold up hello
let somebody else chime in here his
threat is King to g8
I better push the pawn and then well
which pawn there's about five pawns like
a pig here the e pawn okay so so I play
ecigs so if he plays King to g8 you know
I can I can get safe but mister Nisha he
had a plan and he's like I'm sticking
with it right I don't know why I mean I
just played east six the stop it so when
he plays King to g8 even this kid has
only been playing for three months knows
the move I'm gonna make right seven so
easy it's so easy so I don't know what
you were thinking about yeah yeah so so
so there there it is I mean it's pretty
pretty easy when he's gonna play that so
so my nights out okay buddy
so so I'm safe alright so so now his
plan fizzled I mean and so now he
attacks okay h6 all right so I better
move my bishop so now I'm hoping hoping
that he plays this moving and luckily
his face was as red as it was right now
so he was still still doing it so when
he plays g5 i I don't look at the
position I'm just I'm just enraged I
actually take because when he takes my
knight goes here and now it attacks the
bishop and removes but what should i if
I was thinking sound in my right mind
what move should I play here
yeah Knight takes h6 check and then
Bishop takes g5 and if he tries to pin
this I just protect it and life is good
life is real good yeah but but you know
I got the emotions get the best of me so
I I took here I took actually with that
Bishop here Bishop takes d5 pawn takes
knight or actually
so Bishop takes g5 he he takes with Shaq
alright he's took the stuck piece with
check see when people are really really
angry all the time they tend to make bad
moves like like yeah your feelings were
a little hurt when I took took your uh
your took your pawn on g5 huh so so he
wanted to get me back and then it wasn't
really the best way to get me back cuz
cuz now you had an act of peace and and
I didn't so that was a good trade for me
okay so so now he takes my knight takes
and now Knight attacks the bishop so
he's got to figure out a way to get out
of here and he does figure out a good
way to get out of this he actually even
though right now it looks like things
are dire for him I got one two three
four five six pawns and he only has
three he's gonna get get some stuff back
how does he do that
Knight - D - excellent yep alright so so
now I almost think why I might not even
want to give away all these pawns but
then I come to my senses unlike yeah I
have to so now he gets checked and now
he Forks my king and my pawn King to F
Knight fork yes and so now he takes and
so so now I'm a realist in this position
I'm like well 1 2 3 4 this pawn it's
going to be really tough for me to
promote this pawn because he's got his
King over here is rook over here he's a
lone pawn and you know these connected
pawns may be able to do some damage to
me okay so so I'm like well I will trade
my pawn that's going to be tough for me
to protect and hold on to for this pawn
ok but he decides not to go for that
okay so as you'll see
in this game his checks aren't so hot
and my checks are really really good
okay so let's let's keep on track his
checks and my checks alright so he
checks me here alright that's a check of
1 check yeah check all right so so King
up
so obviously I'm not afraid of this move
cuz I'm gonna take his night and here's
get my night and uh that'll be good for
me ok so now he checks me again ok so
now I really have to think here alright
do I want to be wimpy kind of and just
retreat and hold on for dear life like
please don't promote these pawns or do I
want to be strong and try to get my king
up here to help him alright so if I
wanted to get my king up up there to
protect this epon where would my king
have to go in this position to f4 pretty
dangerous because now anywhere this
night goes it's a discovered check but
if you look at all this discovered
checks not very good they don't really I
mean they're checked that's for sure but
they don't have the same umph
okay because he he doesn't get any
material for it okay so so that's what I
do it's dangerous but uh but that that's
what you can do
alright so so he presses on alright so
he's got two connected passed pawns
coming down there okay so I better get
my kit well alright so so here's my
check alright so why is this a good
check because it forces my opponent to
the corner of the board cut off in the
endgame it's good to have an active King
okay so look at his checks that check
helped me move up the board this check
helped me move up the board my check put
them in the corner
all right so see the difference all
right so now this King is cut off from
the game
alright so now I'm marching my king up
now you know now this pawns got some
support you know now this pawns getting
a little bit scary
alright but he's like I got my pawn I'm
shoving my pawn down your throat d3 ok
so interesting all right Knight to f4
threatening Shaq all right I'm gonna
take your rook and everything's gonna be
good and I thought I was doing pretty
well here but black has a really cool
move that not only stops that check but
also threatens his own fork so basically
you know what piece it's gonna be now
all right not all at once what's
everybody sigh here
so Knight h4 Knight h4 stops stops my
knight from coming to g6 alright cuz
obviously we'll just take it and also
threatens Knight to f3 check for King
the king and the rook alright so pretty
scary here ok so so now so now I think
this is this is kind of scary so so when
you're scared you want to make
aggressive moves and just try to try to
hold on here so so what move can i play
that that might really scare him eise
Evan okay so even though it doesn't
react to this move because obviously if
check King move Knight takes I take with
Queen and I win okay make sense all
right so I'm not afraid of that threat
so II seven moves it rook alright so his
threat of Knight to f3 is still on
alright but he's just got to deal with
my threat of pawn takes rook where
should he play his rook
to e8 any sensible person with rook to
e8 and now I can never try to promote
this poem because the rooks they're
right right
all right but but yeah you were going
for the wind with rook the c8 but when
he plays rook to c8 I sit there and I
calculate out the wind
I actually think and calculate it out
you just thought you were winning huh
but you didn't have any proof
I actually calculate it out and I
calculated out all the variations and I
just can sit back and relax because I
know I know I've won now because he but
if you were to play Brooke to e8
everybody like man this guy's good but
Brooke the c8 big blunder okay so so he
should have like respected that my porn
was on e7 trying to promote all right
importance Brooke only eight but so now
I calculate out the win here so first
things first get rid of these dumb
Knights okay because it's much easier to
calculate when there's less pieces on
the board ok so that's check everybody
knows he was gonna play this move so
what more does he play eat d2 right he
wants to try to get a queen here alright
so yeah he's close
he's he PI still thinks he's gonna win
here huh so wait look the d6
alright so now I'm threatening rook
takes pawn and also Shaq all right so
pretty scary so guess who's got to go to
e8 now guess who's got to go to yeah
just a little late just a little late
all right so listen rook to e8 and now
yeah so now there's moves that win for
me there's moves that lose for
this moves that draw for me so if I
wasn't careful all my all my calculation
all my beautiful play would all be for
naught if I play a really stupid move
here and there are some stupid moves
here so let's just shout out so some
random moves that you think I should
play here what we got all right so let's
try King f6 all my hard work for nothing
oh yeah I will take it thank you thank
you and now I play here and
unfortunately my rook is a little slow
stupid rook so you got to be really
really careful here so of course
everybody's going to suggest King e6
right the same thing check King and then
and then c3 game over unless you're a
computer alright I won't get into this
very off I would have just resigned here
if that's what I want to play but but
you could play King of seven and then
here and then and then yeah you just
thread a checkmate a bunch and then
you're threatening checkmate and it's
got to go back and then you can do this
all day a perpetual but but usually I
won't have that those good good tricks
so I could have still drawn the position
but oh okay so so now we know we don't
want to play our King to protect our
pawn or else he'll just take it okay and
force a draw and if we're not close we
might lose all right so what else do we
have here all right rook the d8 so route
to d8 very very complicated very
complicated Queen rook takes King here
rook check King I get a queen check
and now I get a check and complicated
okay
he's got a queen he might force a pour
petrol and it's scary okay
scary all right so so this does give me
a slight very slight advantage but I
can't calculate out the wind from here
okay all right so what else we got six
Jack triple blunder all right so then
then you let the king off the back row
and now what night now you just give it
up yeah all right so so here's the move
rook takes D - all right so now check
King here and now of course check yeah
it was hoping I'd take this pawn and
then up I win I'm the best right yeah
yep and then so yeah I play King to c3
after this check so you see how all of
his checks haven't really helped him out
at all King to c3 all right and yeah and
now it's looking isn't this a pretty
easy position for uh for white to win
here he's up one pawn but I mean it's
pretty easy okay so we just protected
this pawn so what do you think we should
do attack it
excellent Rick to d4 all right so he
sees there's no way I'm gonna be able
there's no way I'm gonna be able to save
this pawn so he's gonna attack this one
a fork just protect it all right so he's
like okay that pie can't get so I'll try
this one
so h4 excellent all right so here we go
here we go
so h4 so now it's getting tough it's
getting really really tough for him all
right so now he plays King to g8 oh no
no first things first he's got to try
try something else here he'll try a six
alright so he wants me to capture it and
then he'll play rook here and he thinks
they'll have something good going so why
give him any kind of counter play all
right so I'll just take this pawn he
takes with Czech and now pawn takes all
right so you see how how I'm doing great
my king thanks to his checks right I've
got my King everywhere I want to be his
king is in the corner he's rather have
this King over here right so he plays
King to g8 alright so what do you think
I should play here nope nope no mister
new so it's not rook to g4 check nope
because those checks would actually help
me alright help you get over there you
see you see oh don't get so mad about
it's just the game its just the game its
just the game alright alright well thank
you for coming mr. nerim thank you for
coming alright alright alright alright
so does everybody see the move I really
should play in this position rook to f4
very good I don't want to be checking
and helping him get to where he wants to
be I just want to play rook to f4 and
now his King can't get anywhere near
that be pawn and the game is uh is very
easy sorry you guys had to see
okay alright so so now it's a pretty
easy game here so he plays there just
March the pawn up rook back King up
check again yeah he loves checks all
right so then check again why not all
right
and now King here rook check King up and
now rook the c6 all right so I really
want to promote this pawn right all
right so what move should I make what we
got look outside there's no reason to
build a bridge we're way past building a
bridge let's just go for the win here
checks yeah yeah you're a pupil of a mr.
Nishimura area you kind of look the same
all right so how do you want to play
here rook to a4 right and now his King
too little too late checks to get over
there but since he was cut off and now
King to a8 and that's all she wrote of
course he's gonna play Chuck again just
because he loves checks I guess kinda
but yeah game over okay and that was the
infamous game and I won the game
and I won the tournament and leaving Tim
Nisha I'm just a half point behind so so
that was that was the the great game
alright so thank you all for coming to
our 6-year anniversary presentation hope
you enjoyed the show